Kathleen is asking how can I upscale my
fashion brand I'm just starting out so
advice for someone who wants to start
out a fashion brand and scale it up
right so I think again a Kathleen you
know you probably know the market in
terms of fashion brands think about who
is it your audience is gonna be who's
gonna be your market you know you're
gonna go for it's a good bit
generational play or is it going to be a
segment of the marketplace and then I
kind of think what is your big idea
about how you get to both the product
and why you're different and then also
what's the best distribution channel who
can you either partner with or do you
want to do it on a website and kind of
through basically digital presence once
you determine that then I'd always
actually honestly kind of test-drive
stuff so you know I believe you Kathleen
should have huge dreams you should be
the next kind of massive fashion icon
walking down you know all the all the
platforms picking up the awards but in
the meantime you've got to take the
first baby step so if you kind of got a
product an idea and you're gonna say
market to either a 16 to 25 year old
females then wouldn't it be good to go
and test-drive it with six or seven of
your friends or again if you're gonna
market it in two guys high fashion
brands then that would be great so get
people around test their ideas and then
actually prototype it then test-drive it
and I actually I know quite a lot of our
customers who have built businesses like
this and one of them in maternity where
actually different business but in
maternity wear and she did it through
our friends first of all and then she
did it through building a very small
website and then she scaled up and I
think she now employs about 40 people
has been hugely successful and really
kind of high-end brands so I think with
all these things again kind of have a
big idea which it sounds like you have
and then understand the marketplace
you're trying to sell it why are you
different what Steve kind of unique
differentiator and then get loads and
loads of feedback so when you kind of go
market you've constantly iterating and
learning as you scale up your business
yeah I think you've got to find a
product that's gonna work gotta find the
unique thing whether it's a special
dress or a new hoodie or whatever it is
you know you're you're creating amazing
new colorful ties for Stephen Kelly to
rock - with matching cufflinks
you gotta show the cufflinks a fatigue
little huh you said can you see that
ever yeah yeah we love colors you see
see I love it I have a new looking cool
in the hoodie man I love that so you've
got to find the thing that is different
about your your brain why is your
fashion brand different than everybody
else's and test-driving I think a lot of
people make a mediocre product they make
you know a t-shirt like everybody else
making a t-shirt and then they buy 5,000
t-shirts is sitting in your mom's garage
you need to find the thing that's unique
about you this is the this is like the
startup before you scale up you got to
start up to find what is the angle
that's gonna work for you and when you
have a part that you know works and
people love it then you focus on the
scaling up he worked on the partnerships
and the distributorships in the
marketing but if you focus on that too
soon you're just burning dollars you're
burning marketing dollars without
something that's gonna work so you got
to figure out what that key product is
first hey Emma just on that I got um
there's sort of top five reasons why
companies fail to go through you know
from startup to scale up the number one
reason the number one reason is 42% of
businesses fail because they fail to
understand the market neat all about
your point about the wrong product and
making sure that it's a great fit of the
market I love it now I want the other
four are you wanna know so what about
the obvious what about a third of them
third of them obviously I guess this is
sad because I think people over engineer
you obviously got to understand e-cash
requires a third of them run out of cash
through a lack of funding or poor
investment or get in the head themselves
so tracking your finance is really
critical obviously that's where people
like the sage can come in and help next
one is a quarter of them go back and say
they actually hired the wrong
people which is interesting we talked
about that less than 20% of them fell
because of competition and then actually
the last one is about one sixth of them
say they had cut our cost or price in
issues with their products so they're
the top five reasons but number one
standing out is kind of the product
related to the market need